that bike
for sure would not make that jump if he
was to try and jump that for real with
the ground clearance weight is and the
weight of that bike
i think both wheels would come off and
the engine would just drop straight out
of the bottom hey gq
my name is rick english i'm a stunt
performer and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up john wick chapter 3 parabellum
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so it looks like these guys are
riding pretty regular naked sports bikes
looks like a 900cc yamaha for this type
of sequence where they're going to be
using weapons
it's good to have a bike like that where
you've got an upright riding position
if you're on something a bit more
extreme a sports bike you'd be a lot
more
hunch forward it'd be a little bit more
difficult to sit up and draw those
weapons with that i wouldn't have
thought that these bikes would be
specially made or custom made for this
sequence the only thing
you might do is change the gearing
slightly because you're not using the
top speed of the bike at all that bike
is standard will probably do like 160
170 miles an hour
and you don't need all that speed so you
can gear that
that bike down so the power is used make
it more responsive on the bottom end and
it's definitely way more useful for film
stuff generally than to have
a real fast top speed
[Music]
i look really smooth actually it looks
doable and when you're doing transfers
for motorcycles is the instability if
you're transferring from a car
to another car it doesn't matter if you
push off of that car with your foot
you're not going to send the car
sideways
a motorcycle though if you if you push
off sideways and the bike chances are
that bike will tip over and the slower
you're going the worse that'll be
and the more that'll be exaggerated the
way it was there is kind of high speed
it was very slick it looks like he's
practiced that a thousand times and i
would say that was probably done
uh in a volume on a sound stage against
against green screen or something like
that
so that was a pretty spectacular crash
we had there so it would be difficult to
do that practically i've got a lot of
money to do that practically
400 pounds landing on top of the guy
there so i would say that's probably
some some digital help
uh with that one there and because they
don't stay on it too long any kind of
discrepancies between real action
and anything cg and enhanced because
you're cutting away and it's quite a
fast moving
clip you can get away with that pretty
well
[Music]
[Applause]
real attention to detail for me with the
riding there
keanu the main character seems to be
performing a lot of the fight moves with
his left hand
and that's obviously because the primary
controls on your bike are on your right
hand
you've got your throttle there you've
got your front brake there so
you take that hand off of the bike
you're really limiting how much control
you have
so you'll see even when he he starts to
use his right hand for
for fight beats he puts his left hand
onto the bar just so he can keep the
throttle open and the bike doesn't shut
off
we've got to say they've probably taken
a bit of artistic license there
if something went into your back wheel
your bike wouldn't flip like that to be
honest
the opposite thing would happen the rear
wheel would lock up and the bike would
slow down from the rear so it would
probably dive forwards if anything
the only way it would kind of flip like
that was if the guy still had his hand
on the throttle
and then it caused him to hit the gas
really hard that could cause the bike to
spin out backwards like that so
i'll say that's probably what happened
in that in that clip there and that's
what they were going for
it's a big deal to film on location
there's a lot involved a lot of
different departments that have to all
come together i think they filmed a lot
of stuff on the stage especially the
fight beats
like on a green screen and then captured
the camera background
shots and plate shots to overlay that
onto
later on i won't see a simpler way of
doing it but it's just a much more
effective way
of doing it to actually film those fight
beats on location
on the bridge like that almost
impossible
[Music]
that's done really well that end
sequence all looks to be in camera
practical stunts uh i would say that's a
stunt double for sure
dublin pikianu i know he's mega into
bikes
he's a great rider but there's there's
no reason to risk an actor for
for a sequence like that he's got no
helmet on he's riding on wet roads he
adds challenges then with grip
for for tyres and stuff so at the end uh
two nice crashes the first one was like
a lay down crash we just caught a
regular bike lay down or low side and
what that is is where the rear tyre
slips away and the rider will hit the
floor and the bike will slide away from
them and that was the first guy the bad
guy rider and then the other crash
that you saw keanu's character do there
is is what we call a high side
and what happens there is the bike slips
away but it flicks the rider over the
top
of the bike or the high side of the bike
they're the two main main kinds of
motorcycle crashes and it's it's really
cool that they got those two to happen
in
in one shot and i thought that looked
awesome next up mission possible rogue
nation
[Music]
i worked on this movie i'm actually the
bad guy that's chasing
ilsa on the motorcycles this was filmed
in morocco it was a disused motorway
just outside of marrakesh
it was all completely closed down
specifically for
for the movie to shoot there so the
bikes we used on this chase were 1000 cc
sports bikes bmw s1000 rr
it's a powerful bike straight out of the
box that things nearly 200 horsepower
capable of almost 200 miles an hour as
standard so it was perfect for
for what we're doing on here most of the
stuff in and out of the trucks that you
see here it was all done
practically um the trucks are really
there the cars are really there
that's myself the other riders and tc
all riding we planned every shot out and
every route out so everyone knew
exactly where they were going because
obviously at that kind of speed she
can't afford any mistakes
first thing tom does is pick up the
sunglasses before he gets on the bike
that's actually quite important because
traveling this kind of speed you you
need eye protection when you're doing
speeds of
you know 100 miles an hour you don't
want to get a stone or anything thrown
up into the
into that that kind of speed and so
really important to have eye protection
even just the wind blaster that kind of
speed you'd be struggling to see
anything over sort of 40 50 miles an
hour and you'll see him leaning really
far forward on the bike here that keeps
the weight at the front of the bike so
the bike's designed like that it's a
race bike essentially
designed to do high speeds so the the
rider wants to be as aerodynamic as
possible so he's fully tucked in on that
bike you know if you're on a naked bike
doing that kind of speed the wind would
just be blasting in your face and trying
to rip you off the back of that
if the cars are doing motorway speeds
you know 60 70 miles an hour
then to make the chase through there
look fast you would have to be doing 140
150 miles an hour so it's just not
practical
so you just back the cars off a little
bit slow their speeds down
say maybe 30 miles an hour and then when
the bikes come through there at 70 80
miles an hour the speed differential
makes it feel so much faster and gives a
lot more energy to the chase
tom's really keen to do as much as he
can the sequences are written for him
specifically in mind that he's going to
be performing
by himself he likes to do his own stunts
rehearsing and practicing
i literally was looking down at my
speeder going yeah that's tom right in
front of me and he's
doing 130 miles an hour right now
there's not many actors i know that have
that level of skill and will be prepared
to do that for their movies
you saw ilsa there uh change up a gear
you could see that through the way she
she pulled the clutch in with her left
hand
now to be honest these bikes and a lot
of modern sports fights will have a
quick shifter
system so you don't actually have to use
the clutch to knock it up a gear
you can just literally hold the throttle
wide open and kick the gear shifter
and that'll change the bike upper gear
without using the clutch but
for films it helps to illustrate the
point that she's
increasing her speed they're wearing
full race leathers
which suit these bikes perfectly they'll
have plastic pucks on their knees and
that's literally so they can touch the
knee on the floor and that just gives
you an extra point of stability also
helps you to gauge
your lean angle for this chase although
the bikes weren't really modified too
much
we did add a little bit of crash
protection on there
i think most uh race bikes these days
it's mandatory to have this little
plastic guard
that that covers the end of the the
right handlebar and what that does is if
you make contact with another rider it
just stops that front brake from being
jammed on
because we just had one instance during
rehearsal where we were rehearsing
a couple of the bikes banging into each
other seeing how that looked yeah one of
the other riders came in to me
his front brake leave it hit my leg and
it hit his brake straight away and it
was close to disaster so we just put
those little guards on there to stop
that happening when we were filming
i would say it took us probably six
weeks total to actually film once we got
to morocco
and then a couple of months rehearsal
back in the uk
before we headed out there still amazing
roads to ride no room for mistakes on
those roads either you know the bike
goes down and it's
off the edge of a cliff so everybody had
to really concentrate and
and be careful
that was practical i did that crash
myself i remember a couple of weeks
uh before we headed out to morocco
myself and the
the coordinator and second unit director
are all big uh motorcycle racing fans
and they've been some racing on the week
before
we'd seen some spectacular crash by one
of the motogp
riders and kind of came together and
said be nice if we could do something
like that rather than just let the bike
slide out when tom
knocks us off that's what we ended up
doing you see the bikes slide away
once i've been flipped over the top and
it goes off at the edge of the mountain
and special effects blew it up
afterwards
it would definitely shake you up but
yeah totally survivable
happens every day in racing uh obviously
tom isn't wearing a helmet there so just
when you're tumbling you would just be
making sure that uh that your head was
protected i certainly would be
really well done pretty realistic yeah i
mean mission was a was a dream job for
me we had a
bunch of the greatest riders in the
world amazing landscape beautiful roads
it's not very often that you get to do a
chase on on actual sports bikes
um they're not used that much for the
chase stuff because the roads kind of
have to be flat and
straight and but they're great for doing
high-speed stuff and i thought it came
out really well
i was so pleased to be involved with it
next up skyfall
i worked on this movie these bikes were
honda crf
250 four-stroke motocross bikes this was
filmed in the main square in istanbul in
turkey obviously those bikes have to
look like they belong there so the bike
the bad guys escaping on there
motocross bike dressed as a police bike
bond is basically riding exactly the
same model of motorcycle but this time
it's dressed like you were going
backpacking across the country or
something
everything is mapped out beforehand and
the routes have to be planned carefully
a mixture of stunt performers and
background artists
we can get them crossing at the right
times to make everything look as chaotic
as possible but keep everybody as safe
as possible
the stunt guy that's backing that
vehicle up he'll have a specific mark
where he's not going to go past as well
until the ride is cleared but there's a
lot of trust there between the two of
them but he'll just floor the bike
make the gap and the stunt guy reversing
that car will be i'll be there at the
right time
[Music]
he's off-road bikes are perfectly
capable of that
no modifications at all you see when he
goes up the stairs there
kind of cut to the outside a little bit
the stairs were a little bit less severe
a little bit more worn away at the side
there so that's probably the route i
would have taken as well rather than
just going straight up the middle there
these guys two of the most skilled
riders in the world making this look
amazing all practical all done for real
on location on
actual rooftops in turkey you have to
plan every part of this route because
if you go onto the wrong part of those
rooftops they're real rooftops and
they're not meant to take the weight of
a motorcycle jumping onto them so
the path of each bike was was planned
precisely this was filmed
a few years ago and it's kind of before
drones became
a mainstream way of filming photography
so a lot of this rooftop section was
filmed from
another motorcycle with a camera mounted
on the front and again that's another
world level rider there and they did
amazingly well
on this movie this was one of the first
times that i kind of saw extensive use
of face replacement replacing a stun
performer's
face with the face of an actor so they
would put tracking markers
on the stunt performers face a specific
points and then they would
track the actors face image onto those
those points afterwards so you can
actually get the act into that scene
i think it's done really well in this
movie it was one of the first times i'd
seen it
in the story it makes sense that the
guys don't wear helmets obviously that
presents
risks for the performance one way to
minimize that risk is to use
a skull cap which should be like a
carbon fiber cap that's that's molded
specifically to each performer's head
a wick can then be attached to the
outside of that or latex to make the
skin
and stuff and it will give you know more
protection
than nothing it's not the same as
wearing a helmet but it just gives you a
little bit of protection there and we
can then
kind of sort out any uh any problems
with that
afterwards in post
[Music]
i was there i was in the bazaar when the
bikes came in
and landed there and that was done
completely for real the glass is
obviously a breakaway
sugar type glass but yeah the whole
thing was completely practical and those
guys had to jump those bikes it was
about i think like a 14 foot drop
between
the top and the bottom too flat
rehearsed it onto
a down ramp to line the shot up so you
weren't risking
the riders and the bikes until the
cameras were rolling and then once the
cameras were rolling the guys just went
for it
again these sections where it's slightly
lower speed you can afford to put the
actors in there
the people along the side they'll be
stunned performers they're aware that
there are
bikes coming through there and they may
get told to you know step
out and then step back in at the last
second as if they're reacting to a bike
coming through
and keeping everything pretty natural
that would have obviously been a stunt
performer and it was done in a couple of
different parts i think i think they
rode the bike in and then um had the guy
on a wire and just
just sent him over i totally buy that
the bike would flip over like that
um it depends how high the barrier is
basically when we do this
if we hit a car or something like that
with a bike it kind of depends on
on how much of the weight the bike is is
above and below if there's more of the
weight the bike is below
the surface it's hitting then it's just
going to get stuck dead pretty much but
if there's
um enough momentum and the barrier is
low enough or the bridge is low enough
then as soon as the wheel hits it the
rider and the bike are going to get
flipped over the top like that i thought
it's done pretty well yeah for any stunt
guy
i mean the pinnacle is kind of working
on a bomb movie so to be
involved in a small way in an epic chase
like that for me was was great fun and
to be there and
and watch it all and fall was was
amazing next up the dark knight
[Applause]
i thought this was a pretty cool idea
actually the only kind of limitation
you've got with that is that then
obviously you've got
these big fat car tires essentially on a
motorcycle so it's never really going to
turn that well or handle that well
but um but looks cool
mainly filmed i think on location in
chicago the bat bike itself was written
by
a french stuntminder called jean-pierre
[ __ ] amazing rider and it's very
challenging to be honest like i say the
tires are
such crazy big fat square profile tires
that that thing will only pretty much go
in a straight line
you'll see a lot of the sequences the
bike staying pretty much straight
and then you know he's only able to make
these kind of shallow turns
that thing wouldn't be able to turn turn
sharp at all
okay so one of the other challenges that
the the stunt guy would have had there
riding this bike
is the cape once you're actually at
speed that keeps flying out behind you
the wind's catching it and it's lifted
away from the wheels
as soon as you want to slow down to a
slower speed and the cape starts to drop
you've got to think that that thing's
going to be wanting to tangle up in the
in the back wheel and that could
definitely cause a problem and
cause you to crash that bike
okay so this is interesting through the
shopping mall there like i say
we're making kind of smooth turns that's
a very slippery surface as
anybody would know and one of the things
that we do sometimes on slippery
surfaces like that where we're going to
drive vehicles through them
is we actually use coca-cola and they
would spray
a thin spray of coca-cola on the floor
there and let it dry
and it would become sticky and tacky and
sometimes that's the only way you can
get any grip
on vehicles
you see as he makes those turns that
that bike is literally on the edge of
that tire it takes a lot of skill to
hold that and to keep it balanced on the
sides of those tires
i'm guessing that's a that's a cg
element obviously the bike came through
the wall
breakaway wall but the bike kind of slid
to a stop and it looked like the front
wheel kind of rotated around itself and
that's batman i'll
i'll let him off with that with some
artistic license there
if that was for real then that's amazing
it can definitely be done but it's a
very risky thing to do obviously
we've seen it in fast and furious with
cars done practically but with that bike
i'm guessing with the instability of it
and everything i would say that was
probably done as a plate shot so they
would have shot the two elements shot
the truck
going along by itself then shot the bike
in the same location going along the
path it needed to take and then just
comp the two of them together in post
the closest thing to a real bike that
exists like that is probably would be
like a drag bike has that same kind of
geometry
a real stretched out look and they're
made for just going fast in straight
lines which is
pretty much exactly what this bike does
uh in this
in this movie but these bikes were
actually practical they were built
for real and i think they had four or
five of them that the special effects
department built i'm not sure how fast
they were and i think
they were they're a handful to ride but
yeah that was a real a real bike
like with the cars there's a lot of
electric vehicles coming out now we
started using those
uh in movies as well and stuff and
there's advantages
and disadvantages of those the main
problem we have these days with vehicles
cars and bikes when the newer the
vehicle
the more sensors and safety technology
is incorporated into the newer designs
and so
when you want to abuse them and slide
them and crash them and do stoppies and
lift one wheel up and that kind of thing
everything on that bike or that car is
telling you not to do that and trying to
stop riders from doing that so
you have to either be able to switch all
that stuff off or disable it or trick
the bike into letting you
play with it a little bit
we tried to do that not exactly that but
spin the bike around
on its rear wheel like that on another
movie that we did and we did it by
having a cable overhead
and i would kind of wheelie the bike and
let them take the weight and then pivot
it around itself but it ends up kind of
clunky
that looks really nice and really smooth
so again that that's that's got to be a
cg takeover
it's not something you could really do
practically it'll be hard work
i think most of this was shot
practically to be honest there's not
really
a lot of places here where you need to
put the green screen elements in there
there aren't beats
of the actor on the motorcycle or
anything that we've got to put in there
or put his face in there because
you know he has the cowl pretty much
this would have been practical with
with the stump rider the whole time i
would guess next up terminator 2
judgement day
[Music]
this movie is um quite a few years old
now but for me this
this chase still stands up yes ed
furlong there riding like a small
a small dirt bike 100 cc honda something
like that and then arnie
big guy big bike harley fat boy
something like that he's got a nice
relaxed riding position there as well
which
enables him to use his weapon and all
stuff while he's riding
one of the challenges you're always
going to have when there's a kid
riding a motorcycle is you're going to
need a stunt performer to double that
kid for all the action sequences
that means you're going to have to have
a stunt performer that's the same size
as as a child basically so i'm i'm
pretty sure that what they did
for this movie was they they used a
stunt performer
you know as small as they could get but
then because they were still
larger than ed furlong the actor um they
had to
use a motorcycle that was slightly
bigger so they probably used you know a
125 or
you know 200cc motorcycle so that in
perspective
it looked the same size pretty clever
way of doing it to be honest and the
audience would never know
the bike that he's on there it's like a
kids dirt bike but they're not toys
that's a real motorcycle so
that thing will probably do 60 or 70
miles an hour could
uh outrun that truck for sure
i definitely would not want to be
imagining the bat wheel by a uh by a big
truck like that i think
uh i think you would probably go down
the first thing first time that thing
that dream you'd be under that truck but
um
they sold it pretty well
[Music]
that bike for sure would not make that
jump if he was to try and jump that for
real with the ground clearance weight is
and the weight of that bike
i think both wheels would come off and
the engine would just drop straight out
the bottom
it was done practically on wires i
believe um and so they're obviously
suspending the weight of the bike on
there if you were jumping a bike and
using like a motocross bike something
that's set up specifically
for jumping then the suspension has got
a long travel and it's going to absorb a
lot of that shock
with that bike i reckon it's probably
got this much travel
before hard parts of that bike are
hitting the floor and all that shock
could be sent through you and uh
that would hurt probably break your
ankles and it wouldn't be nice jumping
that bike off there for real
i'm sure annie could do it he was one of
the strongest guys in the world at that
time it would be hard just in terms of
stability i mean
on his on that big bike so it's quite a
stable bike anyway and you see as soon
as he pulls the kid off the kid's bike
is
straight to the floor and goes under the
back of the truck pretty realistic
i would say that when they did that for
real they'd have been on a
on a rig so the bikes are held in close
proximity together they haven't got to
worry about the controls or the speed or
the balance of the bikes
and he's just got to concentrate on his
action of lifting the kid and uh
and bringing him on i know annie does
ride and it looked like he was riding in
some of the shots there
he's on quite a stable bike it's a it's
a pretty flat road i'm guessing they got
as much as they could coverage with the
with the actor with arnie himself
and then in between the stuff where you
don't see his face and everything then
um
then they'll be using a stunt double for
sure how you film a chasing kind of
depends on
the elements involved in it it's quite
straightforward it would be a
combination of
practical in-camera moves actors
riding the bikes stunt doubles riding
the bikes and then various special
effects elements in there
a lot does go into the planning of it it
can be so different for each
each action sequence next up the great
escape
this is a pretty iconic sequence for a
lot of guys steve mcqueen was one of the
first actors that was kind of known to
to do his own stunts he was probably
better with the bikes than a lot of the
stunt guys that were around at that time
and doing as much as he could and
as much as the producers would let him
get away with i guess
he was a great rider that was his real
passion i think was the the motorsports
you can tell he's super comfortable
riding that bike he did all of this
riding himself pretty much i think even
though that bike
it's more of a road bike really i mean
in those days they didn't have such
focused
bikes they didn't have such highly
modified bikes for the different types
of racing they just used to kind of
modify themselves
but the ground clearance on that bike
wouldn't be wouldn't be great for
for off-road but he's doing a great job
with it when you saw him just there and
he and he slid to a stop you can tell he
knows exactly what he's doing he's using
mainly rear brake
that's because he's on a loose surface
so if you grab a handful of front brake
on a loose surface
you're asking for the front tire to go
away from you and anytime the front
wheel slips away from you on
any motorcycle chances are you're going
to hit the floor you can afford the rear
end to slide a little bit which you did
there he
hit the rear brake it slid a little bit
and he automatically corrected it with
the steering and
and slowed to a stop without even
looking or thinking about it
so although steve mcqueen was as we said
a very accomplished motorcycle racer
uh i believe this jump was done by his
best friend buddykins
again another great motorcycle guy i'm
guessing that was a decision at the
studios they didn't want to risk
steve himself not being able to complete
the movie but i'm sure he was perfectly
capable doing
that himself that's no mean feat on that
bike either
quite a heavy bike short suspension
travel you can see that bikes only go
about this far to go before
parts of that would be hitting the floor
next up ghost rider spirit of vengeance
we filmed this in turkey this is me uh
dublin nick cage
on this movie as the ghost rider that
was all done practically in camera see
we had
another stamp rider and he was on the
side of the bike with his arm over the
top of the bike so he's controlling it
from the side trying to kind of hide
behind the motorcycle
he rides in as he gets to the point
where he wants to slide the bike
reaches his arm over hits the rear brake
with his hand slides the bike in stops
it keeps hold of the clutch
i jump on the bike grab the clutch off
him he stays laid on the floor and i
ride out with him laid on the floor and
they take him out in post
it was very simple but um but pretty
effective way to uh
to get across riding with no rider so
the bikes we used for ghost rider were
yamaha vmax
real big engine i think the 1800 cc
something like that
real big powerful bike they were pretty
standard actually we didn't really
change a lot
except for cosmetically the ghost rider
bike was essentially the same bike but
it was all covered in kind of molten
metal and stuff to suit the characters
so that when the flames and everything
were added in in cg the rest of the bike
was all charred up a little bit melted
like that in the story this bike's going
to be the kind of possessed bike so
it's riding towards him in reality we
call it ghost in a bike actually it's
uh jump off the bike and leave the bike
going by itself
sometimes they can go a long way you'll
see that in motor gp sometimes the guys
will crash
the rider get ejected off of the bike
and the bike will keep going
the more speed the bike has obviously
the longer that thing will stay upright
on two wheels it doesn't want to fall
over the inertia just wants to keep that
thing going and so
they can go pretty far until they hit
something obviously all the fire on
there
is digital this is a supernatural story
so we don't have to believe that that
bike's
actually on fire really although some
guys have
tried to recreate these things so it's
not recommended at all
um but you could like those various
parts of a bike on fire if you had
something superficial on top that you
could burn and we we talked about doing
that for some shots
but at the end of the day to make it
more consistent look throughout the
whole film
the fire was all added digitally what we
do do on the bike it did have
um led lights on it which gives some
interactive lighting so
they would form reflections and shadows
and there would be flickering as if it
was flames
that were creating those reflections and
those shadows just saves the vfx guys
having to put those other elements in
afterwards
all the lead up we do practically as
soon as we get close to the vehicle
close enough to make the transfer
we had a a bike that was attached to the
side of that truck
via two kind of real long steel tubes
and so we would stand on that bike
jump up and then jump across just with a
support wire
uh just in case would have fallen so we
don't get run over by the truck
quite a leak between the uh the bike and
the truck
it has to look a little bit more
supernatural the bike's meant to be
driving by
itself so it has to stay standing up if
you were to to try and make that jump
and kick off of that bike and that bike
was just free riding by itself
probably chances are you'd kick that
thing over as you went to jump off it
and
you won't make the distance to the track
nick cage was actually very decent
motorcycle rider we went out riding a
couple of times
before we started filming the movie and
we had a chat about how much riding he
wanted to do and everything and he was
aware that there was
a lot of specialist stuff in there he
did a fair amount of riding when he was
the johnny blaze character and we
actually see his face and everything
as soon as we're the ghost rider
character and most of that would would
have been uh stunt double for sure next
up the world's fastest india
all right come on
[Music]
that is so sketchy this i guess is the
salt flats in bonneville where they do a
lot
of the speed testing and stuff bikes and
car land speed records and everything
that looks like a pretty typical kind of
vehicle for doing that they would make
the bikes anything as aerodynamic as
possible so they look like rockets
shooting through the the landscape there
they would be covering as much of the
surface area
of that bike as they could in a material
to guide the
the wind around it to create as little
drag as possible to cut through the air
make as little resistance as possible
make the bike go as fast as it can with
the least amount of power possible
as he first sets off on that bike you
see he has a little trouble balancing
and the guys have to kind of stabilize
him the problem is the bike that he's
riding he's got like a fully enclosed
fairing so i'm guessing that he couldn't
get his legs off to to stabilize himself
oh yeah he had the guys there
stabilizing him it looks like because
he wouldn't have been able to easily put
a foot down and uh and correct his
balance
with that big fairing around the side of
the bike this is based on a true story i
believe so they were using a 1920s
bike to try and break the land speed
record i think it's
it's set in like the 50s or 60s they
would have had two
uh two or three of the authentic bikes
that are restored and stuff for close-up
shots
on the set mainly they would have used
something a little bit more modern that
they would then
customize to look uh exactly as the
engine would have looked but to give
more reliability
you know modern brakes and uh and
stability and stuff like that indian is
a brand name of motorcycle like harley
davidson harmo suzuki
it seems to be taking him a long while
to pick up small amounts of speed here
and i guess that's because the bike
would be
underpowered compared to modern
motorcycles a modern motorcycle if you
watch motorgp
something like that those bikes can get
up to 220 miles an hour on the racetrack
in a few seconds but here this bike
would have been geared so
the acceleration on that bike wouldn't
be that good which is why it's taking
him a long time
to to get up to speed there as any road
rider would know is once you get
anything above sort of 70
80 miles an hour you pop your head up
outside of that screen and you're going
to get
severe wind blast you've got our pretty
strong neck muscles then when you start
getting to
triple figures of speed to to hold your
head straight i see he has no peek on
the visor that's a sensible thing
anything like a peak as soon as you put
your head up that would just get caught
by the wind rip your neck back
the stuff he's wearing there the helmet
is pretty basic just the open face
helmet there flying goggles and stuff to
protect his eyes these days guys will
wear
full face carbon fiber um specifically
aerodynamic shaped
um helmets and stuff when they're doing
this type of thing
[Music]
so that things going around really fast
you imagine the back wheels going around
at
100 plus miles an hour so to change
what's driving that around so that's
doing the same speed and then anything
that touches
is going to start start getting rubbed
away pretty quickly you know i can't
believe he's
he's riding in this this gear that he's
uh that he's wearing actually like it's
like a
tweed suit or something
i'd have full levers and everything on
there the wind at that
that kind of speed will just um grab
hold of anything it can so everything
needs to be pretty tight fitting to you
yeah we call it fish time because the
shape it makes resembles a fish kind of
going through the water
the bike's picking up some kind of
oscillation i guess it's just from the
the speed now uh and the the wind
setting up a vibration in the bike there
that when it gets big we call it a tank
slapper
and what's that is where the steering
will go from one side to the other
and you can't really do anything to
control that it'll just kind of either
work itself out or
if you keep accelerating and make the
front end light you can kind of stop it
doing that but once a bike starts doing
that you've got to be really careful
what you do if you just shut the gas you
could almost make it worse because a lot
of the weight will go on to the front
and the bike could
could easily tip over at that you got to
try and keep that bike as straight
as possible the highest speed that you
go
i totally buy that that would happen for
sure um we wrote the the fastest roller
coaster in the world which is in
dubai and they give you goggles to wear
on this roller coaster
and my friend another stunt writer sat
right in front of me
and he kind of looked back to laugh and
this thing's doing like 100 and
how whatever miles an hour and he's got
his goggles were gone like
in two seconds the second he turned his
head the goggles were gone
so i totally buy that his goggles would
fly off if he popped up from behind that
screen there
what is it 201.851
i've probably only done so 180 190 miles
an hour
it's hard to say what would happen at
200 miles an hour in this type of
old-fashioned bike and the old-fashioned
open face helmet no
nobody would do that now for sure they'd
have a lot more protection from the wind
than
than just a pair of goggles you'd
certainly have a visor on
and for me if i was thinking about doing
anything like that kind of speed with
even with a visor
i'd probably tape it down because
sometimes a little crack in your visor
can catch the wind
and rip that thing up even at 70 or 80
miles an hour
when i've seen these um land speed
records bikes crashed before they tend
to barrel
a lot the problem is then that when you
crash you're part of the bike it's like
being in a bobsley
almost to outsiders if you're looking at
that it almost looks like he's riding on
snow and you would think oh that'd be
fine you know but
it's salt and it's really abrasive but
at 200 miles an hour that would go
through your first layer of clothing
pretty quickly
and so you'd want some protection under
there i don't think he even had a scuff
on his helmet which is uh
which is uh yeah he's definitely got
away pretty lightly i've seen guys get
pretty ripped up from a lot slower speed
crashes than that on the salt flats
a lot of the guys that race the drag
bikes and the drag cars
in order to stop the bike in as short as
space as possible and keep stability
they'll have like a parachute that they
deploy that comes
out of the back of that thing and it
literally catches the wind provides a
load of resistance and just
drags the bike backwards and slows it
down from the back like that so
i guess that was his plan was to deploy
the parachute he never got that far but
um
but that's tends to be what they do in
the drag racing world
next up easy rider
a variety of head protection going on
looks like the actors riding for real
harley choppers stretched out front end
big eight hanger bars
these bikes are made for straight roads
they're made made for the united states
i think the eight hanger thing's just
just a look and just a
a cool thing i have ridden a couple of
those for for shows and stuff and
i don't find it the most comfortable i'm
not sure about the advantages of it it
must just be a look thing
because i like to feel part of the bike
and i like to have the bike underneath
me and everything i have the controls in
here and tied to me but but this is a
pretty chilled out position i guess
so that's totally the kind of thing you
would do when you're out cruising with
your friends you'd be
goofing around and making different
shapes on your motorcycles what's cool
as well is
when he goes to get down from the bike
you see that he puts both feet back onto
the seat first and then he kind of jumps
down at the same
time that's because obviously on a
motorcycle you've got to think about the
stability you can't just step on one
side and then the other side that bike
would be all over the place so you
always keep
trying to keep your weight in the middle
so he'll kind of step into the middle of
the seat
and then jump back down so you've got to
think about these things this type of
bikes these um
these choppers and customers and that
there's a real kind of a group of people
that are into that kind of
culture and they like to buy games and
they like to go on meets and hang out
and stuff and it's quite a big thing in
the states
and in the uk for me i i like i like
sports bikes i like uh a great
aggressive ride and that kind of thing
but this is more about the social side
going out meeting up with your buddies
taking a ride out somewhere you know but
in the states this was a big thing and
that kind of lifestyle of the open road
that went with it so thanks so much for
watching these clips with me
it's been great fun see you next time